brasil enfrenta la peor sequía de los
últimos 91 años la falta de agua ya
afecta a muchos hogares e incluso pone
en peligro el suministro eléctrico en el
país más grande de américa latina'
la escasez de agua es un castigo
periódico para los 180.000 habitantes de
itu una ciudad del estado de san paolo
desde el mes de julio
la consigna es racionamiento hay agua
corriente un día así y dos no está
difícil perdemos mucho tiempo por el
hecho de tener que almacenar agua y
nunca tenemos el 100% de seguridad de
que el agua está mente cada dos días
este camión distribuye 20 mil litros de
agua en los barrios más afectados por la
sequía
en todas las casas de youtube se repite
la misma escena
valdés y cubetas repletos del líquido
más preciado y ayer tuvimos agua todo el
día yo conecto la manguera y la manguera
basta de estos baldes aquí hay una bomba
de agua que mi marido usa para mandar el
agua allí arriba y cuando no hay agua
corriente abastecemos gracias al cambio
balde ni si ya se ha acostumbrado a esta
rutina al menos 17 ciudades de la región
de san paolo han tenido que racionar el
agua la venta de tanques ha crecido un
70% y eso aquí esto no pasa sólo es en
todo el país o el planeta entero
necesita agua hay sólo una parte pequeña
del agua es tratada en 2014 y tú
registró una sequía muy severa que
incluso causó disturbios desde entonces
el ayuntamiento ha abierto dos nuevas
estaciones de captación
si no fuese por esta estación de
captación hoy tendríamos una situación
mucho peor que en 2014 los 250 litros de
agua por segundo captados aquí están
permitiendo mantener el racionamiento de
agua en la ciudad el agua llega a haití
a través de una red de 22 kilómetros de
tubos subterráneos
esta planta potabilización
de agua por segundo y hay una obra en
marcha para duplicar la cantidad de agua
tratada
hace siete años cuando tú vivió su peor
crisis hidrológica la compañía de aguas
había sido privatizada y no podemos
gastar agua deliberadamente con la
manguera como anguera en 2017 con un
nuevo equipo de la alcaldía la gestión
de la compañía de aguas fue devuelta al
poder público desde entonces la
administración realiza campañas de
sensibilización
para racionalizar el consumo de agua
programa es clark esta es la prueba más
clara de que no siempre privatizar es el
mejor camino y tampoco lo es
nacionalizar a veces la ejecución puede
incluso ser privada pero la regulación y
el control de un bien único de un bien
natural tiene que estar en las manos del
estado sin amonestado
a 500 km de itu el embalse de nova ponzi
está casi vacío al 11 por ciento de su
capacidad la falta de lluvias se
arrastra desde hace meses
este ambientalista denuncia que la
empresa pública responsable de las
represas vacío esté reservatorio para
abastecer los embalses vecinos
y el nivel natural del agua estaría en
las marcas del puente
si no se hace nada dentro de 10 ó 12
años no habrá más embalse
no va ponche integra un sistema de
embalses que alimentan varias centrales
hidroeléctricas la compañía eléctrica
regula el nivel de los pantanos para
evitar un posible colapso energético
si el agua baja más habrá una mortalidad
de 15 millones de tilapias de
piscifactoría y más de 5 millones de
peces nativos donde vamos a colocar
tantos peces muertos
la piscicultura asegura esta pequeña
ciudad unos ingresos anuales de 27
millones de dólares
este piscicultor que crea un millón de
tilapias tm el agravamiento de la crisis
hídrica
esto ya aconteció el año pasado con poca
agua en el embalse piscicultor perdió
350 mil peces
si el nivel de este embalse baja del 10%
las turbinas de la hidroeléctrica
tendrán que parar brasil vive al borde
de la emergencia energética el gobierno
niega la posibilidad de apagones pero se
muestra preocupado
si puedes apagar una luz en tu casa
apaga la lo pido por favor no use el
ascensor
el caso de nova ponzi sintetiza la
crisis climática que vive brasil
la humedad entra en la franja tropical
que está en la amazonía
floresta la deforestación está poco a
poco interrumpiendo este ciclo de agua
continua que viene desde la amazonía
la relación entre deforestación y sequía
es un hecho para el mundo científico
las naciones unidas alertan que el
planeta enfrentará graves daños
ambientales y económicos si los países
no se adaptan a las nuevas condiciones
climáticas
en brasil la sequía ya está causando
inquietantes fenómenos meteorológicos
estas nubes de polvo nos recuerdan que
el colapso climático está a la vuelta de
la esquina